You've known Tiger Jim Gray
since he was how old and he was
a very young man seven or eight
years old.
So I've known Tiger for almost
four decades and you know John
you've known him from the tour
everybody that I've talked
to loves him.
He's been great for the game
of golf I've known him since he
was 13 years old wow wow
he's he's the most incredible
kid I've ever met in my life I
mean the talent everything that
goes with Tiger Woods is just
incredible I've said he would
break Jack Nicklaus record
probably 20 years ago
unbelievable and you've had
a great career so Jim it looks I
mean for a golfer I mean,
he's had these other injuries
he's had the back problems
certainly this isn't going
to help his golf game
but he's been playing really
well since he's come back from
the last surgery right until
this recent surgery Yeah
but nobody's ever going
to forget to 12 19 when he came
back and won the May the major
championship at Augusta National
to win that masters after not
winning a major for 11 years
and to come back from where he
was the five back surgeries
the knee surgeries The
infidelity scandal the DUI
it's the greatest individual
comeback in the history
of sports to be from that peak
to that Valley back to the top
and now we're just
praying that he's able to get
through these injuries and lead
a normal life and full recovery
but it's the greatest comeback
ever the greatest team comeback
with the Patriots down 23 28
to 3 talk about another go
on that.
But this is the greatest
individual comeback and now
we're just all pulling for him
to live a normal life you know
now you talk about Tom Brady too
you know,
one of the things I love about
golf John and I and I watch
your career and it's always fun
to see you at a tournament you
just you know you bring
an energy to the game that that
I just find infectious as well
and the pressure though when
you're out there and you've won
let's see gold going through
your record PGA champion
as as a rookie the British Open
you won the pressure on a golfer
just to put in a three foot Putt
it's got to be enormous I
don't know it never really
bothered me.
It never has bothered me I go
play golf I'm kind of a blue
collar guy so you know if I made
a Putt back in the day you a 10
foot or two to make 20 grand OK
I just wanted to make the Putt
and I still am the same way I
don't I don't have a career like
Tiger I don't think a lot
of people ever will.
But I play golf for fun and I
have fun.
And that's why I just have
so many people that want to play
golf with me because all I want
to do is have fun I'm not you
know I've had my day you know I
wanted to be number one back
in the day when the brackets
come out N95 is when I won
the British Open I would have
got so many ranking points.
But didn't come out of that
and promise me this you know
so promise me you'll play with
me and Jim Gray that would be
that's bucket list item for me
so anyway I'm praying for Tiger
tonight Thanks guys.